net voilà pour le côté positif mais côté
négatif côté face c'est bien le tribunal
de nanterre vient de condamner des trois
opérateurs français de téléphonie mobile
un maître de l'ordre disons dans leur
tarification et dans l'information de
leurs abonnés en effet ce qui a été
condamné c'est le système de facturation
que choisir l'association de
consommateurs réclame la tarification de
la communication à la seconde près et
non plus à la minute
entamée françois beaudonnet péguilhan
c'est au mois de mars dernier que l'ufc
que choisir avait mis les pieds dans le
plat en portant plainte contre les trois
opérateurs en cause le principe de
facturation après une première minute
incompressibles orange sfr et bouygues
facture par paliers et non à la seconde
une minute et une seconde au téléphone
son compte et une minute trente
le plus lourdement sanctionné et sfr
dans 45 jours il devra facture est de
nouveau à la seconde tous les clients
abonnés avant le 15 mai 2000 au delà de
la décision concrète qui ne remet pas en
cause le principe d'une tarification
tous les cas où tous les trente secondes
c'est pas ça qui est en jeu le tribunal
dit ça vous avez le droit de le faire
par contre vous devez dire clairement à
vos clients comment vous les tarifs et
et combien ça leur coûte le tribunal
reproche donc un manque de clarté dans
la communication mais les clients eux
remettent en cause le système même de
facturation par paliers à chaque fois
qu'on tombe sur un répondeur ont
gaspillé tout de suite une minute et
c'est inadmissible quoi si on téléphone
trois secondes
c'est beaucoup plus cher pour l'ufc que
choisir ce jugement est en tout cas
l'occasion pour tous les clients de se
retourner contre leur opérateur
nous leur conseillons de décrire de se
rapprocher de leurs opérateurs et de
leur dire au départ j'avais une première
minute indivisible et ensuite j'étais
facture et la seconde un appel d'une
minute une vallée minutes une
aujourd'hui ces semaines appel mais
comptait une minute trente
vous n'avez pas le droit je veux revenir
aux conditions du départ dans le cas de
sfr la justice a donc un peu plus d'un
mois pour se prononcer en appel
sinon l'opérateur devra bouleversé sa
grille tarifaire